welcome to this video black roses mr.
Austin's lost hands so g3 how can you
play off beat against that age 5 maybe
it's a bit crazy but why not it's
offbeat let's get this going
Joe so nobody said that I cannot play in
the same time if even with h5 already
played why not play in the center let's
take that's six simple chess but play 96
you might have taken I don't I don't
necessarily want dad okay i wonder if i
should play Bishop f5 in the first place
my image now let's let's play it let's
play it in a solid way it should be
seven Bishop eng sub that's okay I know
it looks with the H move [ __ ] moose
looking kind of out of place but it's
it's it's it's basically a gap for both
sides that doesn't make much sense to
have them in so no big deal
okay so a through yep he wants to go
before interesting nope he doesn't want
to go before so let me do that night 85
to see for that's a typical way to
proceed um yes let's do that
hmm well not too bad I might have
something on the C file Queen B 6 rook
c8 as a natural continuation you might
have a form that could be an idea mirror
maybe before trying to exploit yep well
that's a good idea I think trying to
exploit my somewhat shaky situation here
so what now I think I should take her
away we should see one no Quinn checks
that that I did not expect okay hmm
Bishop c6 not helping much wonderfest 95
is a move
ok I've various ways to to get an equal
position but don't know yeah let's do
that it's it's simple and okay teacake
push-ups is six bc quincy six bishop
defined I'm okay it's a bit of an easy
way out let's say but not a bad one not
a bad play okay so my point is that I
have the better Bishop yonder for the
more active bishop let's see I cannot
activate it easily here my position may
be here for poss 45 I would like to get
my rook activated it's not so easy Queen
f5 maybe that's a good idea Queen f5 and
e5 you see aid so let's go or start with
that and let's start with that no one
treats Queens hahahaha I totally forgot
totally overlooked that wow I totally
overlooked that it is red grids very
cool Wow okay uh yeah takes King g7 I
don't know if I want to take it is very
dry it's hard to imagine that's
something that can be done in this
position rook c3 is coming rook c4 is a
probably very weird way to trying to
play for something
no it's not a good idea that's just
let's just take a three and make a draw
it's a bit boring but ok we actually
lose that pawn oops oops I didn't see
that one
why didn't I go to a 4 that's an
interesting question
we had just just stupid I should really
focus a little bit here it is not that
easy easy a game now still threaten a
six so i think i'm still okay but it
played it in a very weird way and this
end game is also just to draw even the
porn down but it was like completely
completely unnecessary to get I and it's
40 seconds up
check check check no I just stay on the
fifth ranked him basically asking him
what his ideas if he goes FYI go in the
first rank and check from the back
yeah it was very unnecessary to go to to
get to that in time for this place um
can I do this now that is a draw let's
take checking g6 was maybe possible
check check check check
check
36 seconds just have to know blunder
stuff check check check check check
that's not a low e6 it's not necessary
check check check check check draw
offered game yeah yeah holy Gus would
play on a on a window with black on time
oh yeah that was completely unnecessary
to get to that end game in the first
place John ok so let's check them I
really wonder says something better here
I mean this was the the the keep it
simple approach leading to an okay
position it's of course see I just
totally totally not saw that you get
rate quits it's okay but it is not not a
big deal probably but it's just entirely
unnecessary to do it I can just start
with that move it is just about equal
disposition not not much happening okay
when TM rook c8 txtx take so let's check
what is the clearest wrong here here
here what
what is stop fish giving that's a funny
line the deadest stock fish line here
look a five rupee seven and gives white
plus one it's funny it's even a draw
without the poor Nia without day upon
and we saw that in the game it's just a
draw this percent game I don't I don't
think what can win I don't think white
can win how should you win that's it
wrong and it's just wrong I might be
wrong but I think this is just a draw
it's kind of a rare web rare version of
that end game but I think it's a draw
okay well thanks for watching